thank you for the introduction
let me ask a question first who of you
knows google maps
everyone of course
who doesn't okay
who use google maps in the past one or
two weeks
most yeah
who of you knows google earth
who of you used google earth in the past
one or two weeks
one two three
okay four sorry
five okay
okay um i think you you see um
the problem already
a couple years ago
now a mouse is gone a couple years ago i
created a virtual globe actually it
started in 2005
and from 2011 to 15
i developed it in webgl so it was a
browser version it's basically the same
as google earth
i have old screen
old movie here 10 years ago
quite funny quality is not really the
best at the moment
from today's perspective if you see
some data here can fly around you can
zoom in somewhere you can actually jump
to some predefined locations in that
it's a whole sdk you can create such
applications it's not um just a globe
it's a it's an sdk
okay let's wait it flies
actually it's a movie that's not best
quality the quality was better back then
so now we go to the class here perfect
really funny
a couple months ago a student of me
created a new version using another
technology
that's a little bit of focus of me at
the moment i want to have this on mobile
devices actually it's it's transmitted a
5g on a mobile device and it's being
rendered on a on a supercomputer or
something like that and you see the
quality is already much better and it's
it's on a on a regular smartphone
and you also see the data is much much
better than it was 10 years ago
and and the cool thing actually is that
all this data today is open data
i mean even 10 years or 20 years ago
you had big trouble actually finding
data actually it sounds nice but it
isn't really
um so let me talk about the goal i have
at the moment i want to create 3d models
out of
open geode that's very important open we
heard about openstreetmap before a
wonderful thing
and
i really like open data
actually open and free is not the same
let's not go into details there
but i want to create
general 3d objects out of freely
available raster that's aero or
satellite imagery
and i want to use also freely available
elevation data for that
what i don't want to do
today is i don't want to create a viewer
especially in python
pi's is a wonderful language but
i would not really create a 3d viewer in
python there are also the other better
ways to do that
so if you don't really know what's
raster data that's quite simple
it's basically an image you have
something like pixels and instead of
pixels you do have information there it
could be just rgb or it could be
elevation data
um
[Music]
more and more cities today they provide
their data as open data and just
recently i'm from switzerland by the way
in switzerland the government released
all base data
as open data last year
actually in march 21
also maybe thanks to the pandemic they
saw how important it is to to actually
release data
to the public because people can
actually create
software out of that
so we do have in switzerland at least we
do have um these 10 centimeter per pixel
um auto photos so we have the whole
country in this resolution in germany
many cities provide this data to not all
cities unfortunately for example in
berlin you can also get it and in other
major cities and that's quite nice that
we have 10 centimeters per pixel in
every country
if you don't want to use data in
switzerland if you want to use it in
your country maybe you're lucky maybe
there is some data available there are
some entry points for open data the open
knowledge foundation
and the data world link provides some
some
some data sets
one data set i want to look at at the
moment is
landsat it's also freely available
satellite image data actually it's not
only image data
there are multiple bands we see here
is just a rgb representation over the
himalayas
so what do you get from landsat landsat
has different versions now the latest is
landsat 9
but i'm still using 8 because we
have many many more images available so
we have to wait maybe one two years and
then we can start using nine
so how it is um
done you have different bands for
example the first three at first four
bands are visible bands so the spectrum
green blue red
and then you have near infrared you have
shortwave infrared you have panchromatic
you have cyrus and you have thermal
infrared and and that's really very nice
you can do many applications with that
but
now at the moment i'm only interested in
the first three or four bands so that's
the visible spectrum and we can actually
create images out of it
for example here that's created from
landsat which looks quite nice
more or less it's not really fully
zoomed in but that's freely available um
however it looks nice because it was
edited with photoshop or something like
that
if you actually download it it looks
like that
so you have to actually do some work to
to have nicer colors
it's all 16-bit imagery
and one other thing you will notice here
is the black border
i made a little graphic here um where
you maybe see the problem if a satellite
flies around
this satellite is not just north aligned
so
to have a proper image you always get
these
proper aligned image you always get
these
black borders
you have to think about this as a photo
done by the satellite and then of course
if you align it then it is not that nice
anymore
you could actually lose data and um just
remove these black things but if you
actually do that here um you you will
really lose too much data you can
draw some lines there and then it's all
almost all gone
so that's not a good idea
so we have to download many images and
like a puzzle put them together
there is one nice
url
because amazon provides that amazon
provides all data on the cloud for free
you can actually freely download it they
pay for it
so the first thing is if you want to use
pandas for that actually it's nice to
use pandas for that you can download the
scene list it's called um
scene list so um it's it's every every
image is a scene
and you can
then sort by date for example i would
actually use power states the
acquisition date there are several dates
processing date acquisition date etc i
parsed acquisition date
and then
i
take all the pictures with a cloud cover
for example um lower than 50 percent
um you can also try to do three persons
one person zero percent but then we will
not get too many images of course
um
then the other t2 and rt that's already
pre-processed images so with that you
get all the scenes with a reduced cloud
cover
and you have
already a list of many many images
the next step i did
one problem is if we take images like a
puzzle
you have to imagine it's um four or five
years so one one image is five years old
the next is one year old and if you put
them together it doesn't look nice
because something's changed
so you should only take images which are
near to each other but that's also
difficult because you want zero cloud
cover so it's a compromise you have to
do
i always say it's a little bit a manual
process too it's not fully automated
like i show it here so i at the end i
actually choose it
by eye but one thing i did is i want to
have summer on all images i don't want
to have winter because the snow cover
really varies among different years and
then
it's really not that nice so let's use
summer and for that i just take the
acquisition months greater than six and
um lower or equal to eight
for the northern hemisphere and of
course um winter on the southern
hemisphere is different it doesn't
really matter because um
but to be perfect i i did that from
december february on the southern
hemisphere i mean in australia you will
not have much snow cover so it doesn't
really matter too much there but um
still i i did it
this way
and then we have all the um scenes in in
the summer months
okay so
i took two you see um you actually
actually don't see it because the the
projector is too dark but
if if you see it on my screen or on a
brighter screen you will see there is
actually some small difference between
the two images here
um and you can imagine we take more more
more together four five six seven to fit
it together and then you get
after a while you get all the coverage
of the whole planet
which is really a lot of work um to do
that if
as i said some manual i'm looking at the
images is involved there too i i
maybe this machine learning that could
be done something but i i highly doubt
that at the moment it's still the human
eye looking at the images which ones fit
the best
so um
how is it done reading raster data i
recommend two libraries actually only
one library if you use python
it's rasterio rasterio is is a very nice
module
created by mapbox for reading
geospatial rasters so rasters with a geo
reference so every pixel has a position
and it's based on gdal gdal is a
geospatial data abstraction library used
in every major software if you know qt
case for example it's it's used there
our keys all the big gis use gdal it's
open source
um
library and it's not really pythonic
there's a binding there but it's it's
it's really a mess
from the from the
from a python um
perspective let me say that
previously i used that in c plus plus
that's okay but if if you have some
really strange commands like open with a
big o or these things or function names
with big letters that's not really
common in python so they created a more
passionate way to do that
and of course one one thing in rust here
is it's the numpy directly numpy so you
get numpy arrays that's also very nice
actually in gdal you get numpy rs2 but
it's a mess there so don't even get
started
so how is it done it's really done in in
three four lines of code so you open
data set you read the rasters like rgb
red green blue
and then you can put it together with d
stack numpy and then you can display it
as an image using matplotlib or whatever
you like or you can store it again as
another file
and then you can actually access all
all
the values there
one thing you notice maybe is the
background is black background that's
just black it's a black pixel zero zero
zero
um so i actually i struggle with that a
little bit because there could be a
black pixel in the image so
however it's it's a it's a 16-bit image
so the probability there is really a
16-bit black pixel in an image is is
really low so um
i create a mask out of it to just check
if it's zero 16-bit zero and then i
create this mask and then it's it's
transparent i will show an image um soon
one thing is of course you have to
reproject
all the images are in a different
projection system it's in the it's every
every um
tile for example is a different utm zone
um along the uh
longitude so you have to reproject it i
did that with gdl tools gdl comes with
many tools and one tool is cheetah warp
where you can just reproject to wgs 84
for example it's the epsg code 4326 epsg
by the way is the european petroleum
survey group and they have all the
projection systems
in a numeric way
so um that's done for each tile i just
did it with two here
and it looks like that i put it in a map
so you can see it really fits
and the background is not black anymore
so that's that's nice
um and the next step i didn't show here
is actually to create one big image out
of all the tiles and that can be done
using a virtual raster data set called
vrt
so let me just just one part now and
we're running out of time soon let me
see oh it's really
i fear that
so we can already retrieve images there
obviously 50 minutes no problem we can
retrieve images
of the whole world
if we have local data sets as i said
before from local governments like
switzerland germany they have really
nice data sets
in the us to have nice data sets too
and
you can have 0.1 meter 0.5 meter per
pixel resolutions or
if you have some remote locations then
you can get the 30 meter data set from
landsat 7
and if you have a
big pocket of money you can you can buy
data sets from satellite providers
if you say no i don't want to have free
data sets it's available
um there are many um companies providing
that data but it's really it's really um
at the really high price tag
you probably saw all the images from
ukraine for example it's more or less
there are some providers really um
giving the data they give it for free in
crisis
zones usually and you could download
that there but usually you have to pay
for all the data
so
the next step is elevation data
there are some near global data sets
available
if you are looking for data sets of the
of antarctica for example
very high mountains there too
that's a little bit more difficult to
get
usually the global
data sets that go up to 60 70 degrees in
latitude
so
you have to specially search for them so
the two big ones are srtm the shuttle
rather topography mission which is
already quite old but it's a global data
set with 90 meter per pixel resolution
or the astra data set with 30 meter per
pixel and then again you have the local
data sets you can get from many
countries as open data
for example in switzerland we have a 10
centimeter per pixel resolution now
available which is over the whole
country actually the whole country in
the mountains is a little bit less
resolution but in the cities
it's 10 centimeter pixel which is
really really nice
actually it's wrong it's 50 centimeter
but it doesn't matter
so reading elevation data
we do it the same way like we did with
the with the rgb data sets so i read the
elevation data just with one band and
then we can
access it using this numpy
array and have the elevation value of
every pixel what i usually do if i have
such an array is create a so-called
hillshade there is the gdal dem
utility um you can just call cheetal dam
hilljade
input tiff or whatever format you have
and you get an output tiff with a
hillshade
you can have more parameters you can
have the direction of the sun etc but
it's already nice to have such such a
thing it's much better than
such a thing here um then you see
actually some
some of the data so okay now we have
elevation data and now we have
image data available now the next step
is let's create a 3d model
creating 3d models is quite easy if you
use the most easy available 3d format
and in my opinion that's
that's the
wavefront obj format
it's really simple first you have a list
with starting with we you have a list
with coordinates
and for example here is a cube you have
the coordinates of all edges we the
first second third and then at the end
you have eight
vertices defined
and then after the definition of the
vertices you have to face this
it's basically polygons so you connect
one two three four actually on this
and this image i started with zero
the index in the obj format starts with
1 which is quite
amusing sometimes because i forget it
from time to time and then you start
with 0 like this graphic here so 1 2 3 4
would be would be 1 zero one two three
you see it's the top polygon and then
you have the next phase one five six two
so it's zero four five one which is is
um down there so you can have all the
faces and at the end
you have a 3d format one thing you have
to keep in mind is you have to be
counterclockwise in the polygon
definition
and you can actually do that you can
create such
a 3d object
now to create a 3d object from elevation
data
you just
take
something like a checkerboard and then
you just
take the vertices and align
the
elevation value i i took
y as as elevation not said i use the x
set axis for
the plane and then y for the elevation
reason for that is
that most local systems are or many
local systems are left-handed coordinate
systems um this can be adapted if you
are in a country with a right-handed
system
so um
i don't want to go into details with the
code here just i want to
tell you that's really simple
first you just put the vertices there
that's the first part this for loop and
the second for loop is the indices so at
the end
you do have um
i have 10 minutes so let me come to an
end soon
let me have time for questions
so i did that for some
parts of the world
you see it this is a wireframe now just
to show um
that it actually worked and you can do
that
then i applied some of the freely
available
um textures
actually images and it looks
like that
okay so that's it we have time for
questions but before we come to the
questions um
if you like geo and you like python
there is the yearly geopython conference
back in reality and back in the physical
world
actually it's also a hybrid format so
you can enjoy it also from your sofa or
wherever you want to enjoy it so
if you're interested feel free to look
more at it
geopyson2022 and now
we have time for questions
i hope
so
thank you martin and we don't do not
have any questions like though so if
someone here in the room have some
question can
raise the hand
and those people at home you can use
slido
thank you for the talk i wanted to ask
uh
yes sorry i wanted to ask you if using
the same techniques for building so very
low scale
in the case how do you deal with
the order of vertex
on triangles for internal faces because
it's basically yeah it's basically the
same
the problem is city city there are many
city models available now even textured
for example in rotterdam has a wonderful
big textured city model the problem
there is it's often
often the texture size is really huge so
you have to find a way to reduce the
amount and you have to work with level
of detail techniques you can't just put
you can't just visualize the whole city
in
in in one part so that's that's um quite
difficult but it's basically the same
thing um
you can create that you can create obj
out of that if you have
if usually it's available in ctml and
then you have to convert it for example
you can use python for that
of course
and what
i did a couple years ago is
we heard about openstreetmap
sweep map actually has some 3d
information in there so there is a roof
type for example and there can also be
really geometry
and some buildings
[Music]
in
open street map they really have a 3d
representation
for example the tv tower alexanderplatz
is an example it's really available
fully in 3d on openstreetmap and you can
actually extract that and then display
it
on your
favorite device
yeah i was like just because when you
have an internal and all in a building
you you have always a problem finding
out which face is inside or outside and
i was wondering if there was yes that's
that's done uh because it's
counterclockwise you have to define all
polygons counterclockwise and then you
know which what's inside what's what's
outside
so um it's um yeah it's
backface culling it's called the
renault technique you need to have a
counterclockwise definition
okay we have a question on slido
how long does it take to calculate all
the polygons i experienced some problem
with computation time for larger areas
i don't have internet here or just show
live
it's really fast i don't know what you
did
um
um
[Music]
i mean it depends what do you think
about huge okay i can't ask back i think
but
um
[Music]
i just did it recently a really huge
error with
millions of vertices and maybe it takes
a couple minutes maximum okay if you say
minutes is long time okay maybe
but for me it's not a long time to
calculate
i mean um
when i did the virtual globe sometimes
you had to calculate the week two three
for uh for a country so that's and it's
it's fast this is really parallel
processing and everything and you can be
happy to be finished in a week too
for example if you take the whole data
set of switzerland images that's a
couple terabytes so maybe six seven
eight terabytes
and processing data there processing
seven terabytes it takes time i just did
it recently um
in three days and i'm happy to
that it only took three days
one thing of course if it's slow
invest in ram
ram is the most important thing i do
have in my mesh in my linux machine i
have 192
gigabyte of ram
and
no that's that's that's
some some people invest in in in
processor power
you can buy the best processor you can
waste money on that that's fine but i
think uh investing in the ram is much
more important
okay we have one other questions about
performance i'm i think you already
answered but you can't still i'm still
interested i don't know if there is
other
people in the room okay okay and there
was a question too
answered okay yeah
my question is um
so for these kind of 3d models what are
the use cases who who who are the type
of people that are using these things
that's a good question as i said in the
in the beginning who used google earth
in the past two weeks and we saw it's
just um okay here's a geo track so um
it's already over represented a certain
way
but that's a big issue
nobody wants 3d
there are some use cases for example
um
for um solar panels
and these things i'm
okay that's that's that's nice um but
it's it's you're right 3d is still a
niche and and not really ready
and i try to work on that already 20
years and still not ready maybe in 20
years i will give up
[Laughter]
or still try something
does it work yeah okay thank you for the
talk
how would you compare the ease of
hunting for data
for instance
to 10 years ago when you did a similar
project
is it easier to get an open
or free data today are there databases
or you do you really need to dig into
the governments and whoever has won
one thing is
compared to 10 years ago
we do have much faster internet again
so data is really downloadable i mean 10
years ago you had to ship hard disks
hard drives
today you can really download everything
you can download i just downloaded a
couple terabytes
two weeks ago so
no one cared about it if i did that 10
years ago i would get call from our id
department
so that changed certainly
and also the data availability is much
higher it's free now
for example the data set of switzerland
cost it
in the year 2005 it costed a million
euro
the data set if you wanted to buy it and
i couldn't afford that
there was
there was um
as a researcher as a poor researcher
we could get it for 1000 euro as as
research institute so
but we couldn't provide it to other
people and and that really changed open
data as it has arrived it's not perfect
yet
[Music]
we saw we see some drawbacks and we see
people scared about providing data
we see conflicts in the world and it's
still
maps are still a military thing more or
less i mean if you know where everything
is located that's
it has some disadvantages so governments
usually don't some governments don't
want to pride all data sets so that's
still a fight but more and more provide
the data sets and i think that's still a
good thing
and and
that's really changed from 10 years ago
we finished the time i think you can
continue asking questions to martin
after the session
thank you all let's give martin a round
of applause
[Applause]